dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir the work we are
going to discuss today is about visual
microphones what does this mean exactly
the influence of sound creates surface
vibrations in many objects such as
plants or a bag of chips foil containers
water and even bricks need thereby work
as visual microphones now hold on to
your chairs because this algorithm can
reconstruct audio data from video
footage of vibrations what this means is
that if someone outside of your house
pointed a high-speed camera at the bag
of chips when you start talking in your
room he will be able to guess what you
said by only seeing the vibrations of
the bag of chips in the following
example you will see a recorded footage
of the bag but the movement is so subtle
that your naked eye won't see any of it
first you'll hear the speech of a person
recorded in the house then the
reconstruction from only the visual
footage of the bag mary had a little
lamb whose fleece was white as snow and
everywhere that Mary went that lamb was
door to go and this is what we were able
to recover from high-speed video filmed
from outside behind soundproof glass
this is just unbelievable here is
another example with a plastic bag where
you can see the movement caused by the
sound waves
the paper is very detailed and rigorous
this is definitely one of the best
research works I've seen in a while the
most awesome part of this is that this
is not only an excellent piece of
research it is also a great product and
note that this problem is even harder
than one would think since the frequency
response of various objects can be quite
different which means that every single
object vibrates a bit differently when
hit by the same sound waves you can see
a great example of these responses from
Briggs water and many others here what
it will be used for is shrouded in
mystery for the moment even though I
think this work provides fertile grounds
for new conspiracy theories the author's
don't believe it is suitable to use for
surveillance someone argued that it may
be useful for early earthquake detection
which is an awesome idea
also maybe it could be used to detect
video reading and recovering beeped out
speech from videos and I'm sure there
will be many other applications the
authors also have a follow-up paper on
estimating material properties by
looking at how objects vibrate awesome
do you have any potential applications
in mind let me know in the comment
section and there's also a fantastic
Tech Talk and paper video on the topic
that you can find in the description box
alongside with a great reddit discussion
link I urge you to check all of these
out the videos are narrated by Abe Davis
who did a great job at explaining their
concepts thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time